let's say at Jack holds both balls above
his head and then he drops them at
exactly the same time what do you expect
to see well they can hit the ground at
the same time I expect them to both land
at the same time same time where's that
now the black one clearly feels a lot
heavier
so the standard misconception is to
believe that the black ball will
accelerate at a greater rate and reach
the ground first this year many people
had an idea that both balls would land
at the same time but they didn't know
exactly why I found there were some
different misconceptions for example
many people seem to think that as an
object falls towards the earth it falls
with a constant speed from this hot yet
pretty much just a constant speed all
the way down spate yeah I think it'll be
the same constant speed
I think it's constant that's the answer
whereas the truth is the speed of both
balls is changing all the time the balls
are speeding up as they go towards the
ground that's what the force of gravity
does on them it makes them accelerate it
gets them to speed up another
misconception I discovered was that some
people believe both balls should have
the same gravitational force on them
even though the black ball is clearly
much much heavier the reason I think
they said this was because they knew
both balls needed to reach the ground at
the same time so they reasoned that the
force on them must be the same tell me
about how the gravitational force on
this ball compares to the gravitational
force on that ball it's very very
similar in terms of gravitational pull
they both are the same and they'll fall
at the same rate I'm like Einstein but
same gravitational force around the
whole world so pull on the earth is the
same on both objects are you saying that
the force on them is the same the pull
is the same but you felt the pull and
you've told me the pull is different no
I said no wait is everyone's gonna pull
this around it is heavier and has more
gravitational pull but when I drop them
then they get equal the gravitational
pull something happened don't you think
it's gonna be like five times as much
yeah you think but it's not the way
you're asking it yes what scientifically
speaking
gravitational force on both these balls
are the same the gravitational force on
both of these balls is the same is that
what you actually believe no but it is
tell me what you believe I believe it
should be more on this simply for the
fact that this is heavier and I just
intuition tells me that it should be
more but after learning physics we
learned that it is actually the same I
actually think the force on this ball is
more than a force on this plate I'm not
trying to mess with you so like in real
life in real life and in physics I will
tell you that the force on this ball is
more all right ready 3 2 1 I would say
the force on the medicine ball is like a
lot more because it's got a lot more
weight it's got a lot more mass yeah but
it's got a lot more inertia yeah yeah oh
you guys remember that right it's got a
lot of resistance to acceleration so it
takes more force to get it accelerating
at the same rate as this ball and that's
why they accelerate at the same rate
thank you guys so much thank you long I
appreciate that